we've got 26 million people who are
unemployed underemployed marginally
attached in the labor force we'd have to
be generating half a million jobs a
month for almost two years just to get
back to where we were before the crash
that's a level of job creation that is
absolutely unrealistic and the current
discourse about how to get there is is
woefully inadequate the current
discourse is saying number one cut the
deficit which will further undermine
demand and job growth plus its view as
well let's just try and get the economy
growing and the jobs will somehow
trickle down to the people who need them
that's not the way that mass
unemployment which is what we've got
today has ever been solved and to add to
that there's a dimension of this that
hasn't been recognized in the
conversation that this country is having
which is that we have created a powerful
barrier to job creation in the way we've
structured hours of work for about 75
almost a hundred years beginning in the
late 19th century the country took a
significant portion of its economic
progress of its productivity in the form
of shorter hours of work so it grew it
had increasing income but also workers
got shorter schedules we got Saturday's
off we got eventually you know move down
to something like an eight-hour workday
the concept of a 40-hour week now that's
a completely normal thing to happen and
all of the wealthy countries went on
this path we would never have been able
to reabsorb all the labor that gets
displaced in the ordinary operation of a
capitalist economy if we hadn't done
that because productivity growth is
always generating a reduced demand for
labor we have industrial restructuring
that's going on all the time
some products get popular others decline
so we've we've got to have a way of
reabsorbing the people who are laid off
in the normal course of a market economy
if you don't have reductions in hours
it's it's almost impossible to keep your
population fully employed which means
that when we try and create a job in
this country we've got to generate
somewhere between sort of 10 and 20
percent more revenue and sales for every
job than the European countries have to
so it's a it's a real barrier to job
creation if we had shorter hours of work
if we were able to take productivity
growth over time in the form of shorter
hours we could reemployed owes 26
million under and unemployed people much
more rapidly
for individuals who want to really
secure their economic futures I think
one of the most important principles
going forward is going to be
diversification diversification of your
income sources of how you meet your
daily needs and diversification in terms
of where you invest and this gets us
back to that principle of how what is
wealth and a broader notion of wealth
which includes wealth in the planet it
includes money wealth of course but also
wealth in people if we invest in
relationships with other people that
that becomes a source of wealth so this
brings us back to the question of time
use if people are able to work fewer
hours in the labor market it means they
can take that freed up time and begin
meeting needs in new ways which reduce
their necessity to depend on that market
that market which as I argue is going to
be less less like loop that market which
is going to be less stable and less
lucrative so for example in the book I
look at people who are involved in a
variety of things called high tech self
providing but basically making and doing
for themselves outside a formal market
structure they might be growing
vegetables they might be raising
chickens they may be generating
electricity on a small scale off the
grid they may have solar solar
collectors on their roof or a backyard
windmill they may be involved in sharing
schemes so they don't have to lay out as
much money to get a appliances or cars
or other forms of transports because
they may be sharing with their neighbors
and creating economic interdependencies
that are going to serve them well when
times are a little bit rocky